ALEX WHEATLEY: I love the game.
I love the sound of the ball
when it goes through the net.
I love a perfect pass or when
you get a stop on defense,
like a block, or a
steal, or anything--
any sort of good play.
I love the rhythm of the game.
I'm Alex Wheatley.
I'm a junior from Upper
Holland, Pennsylvania
and I'm majoring in ecology
and evolutionary biology
with a certificate in global
health and health policy.
The lessons I've learned
on the basketball court
translate really
well off the court
as well, in service and
just in life in general.
This summer, I spent eight
weeks in Kenya working
for the Conservation Clubs,
which is a really, really
awesome program
that teaches kids
fifth through eighth grade
about conservation and biology
and just the
environment around them.
After graduation, I will enter
the Woodrow Wilson School
as a SINSI student, which stands
for Scholar In The Nation's
Service Initiative.
It is a four-year program
that covers a master's
in public affairs at
the Woodrow Wilson School
and a 2-year fellowship
in the government.
In the classroom, I think hard
work, especially at Princeton,
pays dividends.
It's not easy here.
And the challenge is good.
And I'm challenged
in the classroom
and on the basketball court.
And I think that
just common theme
helps me work harder and do
better on the basketball court.
I think as far as
service goes, working
for something
bigger than yourself
is present in service
and on the team.
I'm not playing for myself.
I'm playing for the team.
I'm playing for the program.
I'm playing for Princeton.
So I think that's another
common thread between the two.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]